the legend of zelda links awakening is a
trip back to a simpler time when
handheld game systems had monochromatic
screens and two buttons were all you
needed to go on a grand adventure the
new switch remake marks the second
revival of the gameboy classic and it
brings the quirky co Holland Island back
to life in style the revisions
drastically enhanced the look and feel
of the environments and characters all
the while map layouts and puzzle designs
remain incredibly faithful to the source
material antenna has implemented a few
other new features and some new
collectables that will keep veteran
players on the hunt but the renewed
presentation is easily the star of the
show
from little pixelated people to shiny
cartoony toys come to life
everyone in Link's Awakening brings
newfound energy it's equally true for
monsters and bad guys as well Game Boy
games have their retro appeal but the
remake cast aside ancient aesthetics for
something entirely different that works
on its own terms that which existed only
in our imagination before comes through
in new animations accompanied with
lively sound effects and music that make
you feel like a kid again it's the sort
of look that grows even more attractive
over time and you might like I did start
to imagine what other Nintendo
properties would benefit from a similar
visual upgrade it can also be the one
thing about the game that frustrates as
the framerate takes a noticeable hit
when most scenes load into memory it
seems to be an effect tied to the game's
pronounced depth of field effect which
employs an exaggerated blurring effect
to enhance the miniature toy feel of the
presentation it may also be an effective
the game's very minor load times which
if true makes the compromise easier to
swallow Link's Awakening will no doubt
feel old-fashioned it's a tightly
designed adventure on a small but dense
map 8 puzzle filled dungeons comprise
the bulk of your journey and you're also
required to meet and greet the
inhabitants of the quirky Island link
washes ashore after a calamitous boating
accident to find himself stranded in
paradise or would be if not for the
nightmares residing in the affirmation
faults
this setup suggests that Co Holland
Island is but a bump in the road
compared to the embattled and sacred
kingdom of Hyrule an inconvenient pit
stop for old link if you will yet Link's
Awakening never feels like it's trying
to butt up against the series more epic
entries it works instead as a fanciful
Side Story and it ultimately stands out
for its playful attitude and moments of
bitter sweet melancholy by and large the
flow of the game is managed in a clear
fashion a sage like L helps guide link
from one primary task to the next with
each dungeon comes a musical instrument
and with them all says the wise owl link
can secure his way off the island
the owl always appears at just the right
time when one task ends and the other is
about to begin
but you're also afforded advice from a
shy man named Aurora for the remake you
also have the new option of revisiting
past conversations via the map menu and
the ability to mark locations on the map
using a small selection of different
icons with the switches expanded button
layout Link's Awakening is a lot easier
to plan out because you have access to
more items at once
without jumping in and out of your
inventory in the past you can only have
two items in hand at any given moment
I'll switch Link's sword shield - and
power bracelets strengths are always
ready to use and two configurable slots
for other items let you juggle even more
in any given moment this greatly
diminishes the annoyance of constant
menu flipping and can make certain boss
encounters feel easier than ever
[Music]
for players that want a challenge in
battle a hero mode does exist where
enemies don't drop health replenishments
and link takes twice as much damage as
usual largely however the more
manageable enemy encounters aren't to
the game's detriment Link's Awakening is
primarily focused on testing you with
its circuitous dungeons in an
overarching item trading quest line that
requires you to take a closer look at
the people who call Koho in tome their
identities and stories aren't all that
deep your interactions and exchanges
help shape the identity of the locale
and brighten up your time spent outside
of dark and dreary dungeons
inside fluctuating obstacles and subtle
environmental cues ensure that the
latter dungeons will either test your
memory of the original game or your
present observation and deduction skills
there are times when you suspect that
you've explored every option yet can't
find a path forward as is par for the
course
you probably need to take a closer look
at your tools and surroundings even if
it won't test your fighting spirit links
awakenings most challenging puzzles will
push your intellect in challenging ways
like many of the best zelda games Link's
Awakening gives you a sense of purpose
motivates you with discovery and growth
and delights you with its charming
personality these qualities
unfortunately don't carry over to the
remakes other big addition the dungeon
maker mode here with the help of the
series favorite gravedigger Dante link
can create virtual dungeons derived from
rooms seen throughout his adventure
amiibos can also factor in either as
portable storage for sharing your
dungeons with other players no you can't
upload them online or as a means of
unlocking special features for your
custom dungeon the Link's Awakening
amiibo for example will introduce shadow
link as a mini boss defeating him or
simply playing dungeons will net you
extra consumables like bombs and arrows
these are good options to have and
there's some delight that comes with
laying out your own dungeon but because
you are limited to pre-made room tiles
and for the most part disposable rewards
a dungeon maker mode is easy to dismiss
it's a curiosity at best and definitely
not the zelda maker you might be waiting
for
though the remake has a couple of
blemishes it's still an easy game to
recommend people speak of Link's
Awakening as the secret best Zelda game
that's a tough call to make but it's
definitely one of the best if it's been
years since you touched a classic Zelda
game it will almost instantly transport
you back to the 90s it's simpler in many
ways but the orchestrated journey still
conveys a sense of adventure and this
new version is without question the best
way to experience it and more than
anything else it will put a smile on
your face remakes are a dime a dozen
nowadays and often easy to overlook
don't make that mistake with Link's
Awakening
[Music]
you
[Music]